you want to talk about our some synonyms
here so product maybe you see the word
product that means times or multiply
with means divided difference means
subtract some means add less than means
minus or subtract twice means two times
right and more than means plus so let's
see if we can kind of translate the
sentence into an equation so the
quotient of a number and negative four
increased by two is twenty okay let's
take it piece by piece so quotient means
divide so the quotient of a number which
we don't know what the number is let's
just call that N and negative four which
is then increased by two so we're adding
two because it's going up as increasing
is mean z equals 20
okay now sometimes students get a little
confused when it says quotient they know
it means divide but is it n divided by
negative 4 or negative 4 divided by n
well it's always going to be the first
number divided by the second number okay
so that should clear that up so
basically you know when you see quotient
of a number and negative four it's gonna
be that first number divided by the
second number okay
increase by that's going up and then
whenever you see the word is that's
equals and then you can solve it from
there let's go to the next example 15
less than three times a number is
negative 28 okay now what confuses
students about this problem is that they
see less than and they think okay 15
minus three times a number well when you
think of less than what it means is
you're taking away something from three
times the number so three times a number
is 3 times n 15 less than that means we
have to subtract 15 the mistake those
students make is that you know they just
start directly translating word-for-word
so they say 15 okay I put 15 less than I
put minus you know so with less than you
have to be a little bit careful
lastly means you're taking away 15 from
3 times a number so it doesn't follow
word-for-word in the same order okay and
then is means equals negative 28 and
then you can solve from there the last
example let's look at this one the
product of a number and 7 is negative 21
oh so a product we know means multiply
we talked about that there so the
product of a number
and seven so n times seven is means
equals negative 21 this one was kind of
an easy one product it doesn't matter
the order because product means multiply
a multiplication is commutative so but
normally I would just put the number
first and then second number second so
that concludes a little bit about how to
work with translating sentences into
mathematical equations so I hope this
helped you understand it better
subscribe to the channel check out some
my other math videos on Mario's math
tutor and YouTube channel and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon